in a video she released early this month
that calls on President Joe Biden to
support a ceasefire in Gaza specifically
a segment of that video that depicted
protesters in leb's home state of
Michigan chanting the phrase you see
there from The River To The Sea the
contention is that this this is a call
for a kind of anti-colonial expulsion
and so I want you to explain like what
you mean by it and why you used it or
why you include it in the video Don't
distort the words of my residents many
people in this movement for human rights
for Palestinians have always centered
around coexistence no matter your Faith
your ethnicity your background you
should be able to live without fear
without discrimination without this kind
of inequality that you know netanyahu's
extremist party and his leadership has
been pushing when they talk about it
being free they are talking about
getting rid of the roughly 8 million
Jews and you'd probably have to get rid
of about two million Muslim Arabs who
live there and the Christians and the
bah and everybody else you can't say
they want coexistence when they're
chanting things like kill the Jews
calling for violence not just subtly
overtly calling for violence